-Our first guest is a two-time
Super Bowl champion
and a Hall of Fame quarterback.
He's also the host and producer
of "Manningcast" on ESPN2.
Ladies and gentlemen, please
welcome Peyton Manning!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Peyton, good to see you, bud!
That's what I'm talking about!
-Hey, Jimmy.
-Peyton, it's great to see you.
Welcome back.
You had a great cameo
on "Saturday Night Live"
during "Weekend Update"
this past week.
I loved it.
Colin Jost wanted to have you on
to talk about football,
and all you wanted to talk about
was "Emily in Paris."
[ Laughter ]
I want to know,
have you ever seen
an episode of "Emily in Paris"?
-I've never seen an episode of
"Emily in Paris."
Not sure if I'm going to
in the future.
I feel like I know so much about
it now, Jimmy.
But I think I'm going to be
asked to be
in season three,
like a big part.
[ Laughter ]
-It was well done. It's so good.
I have to ask you because
everyone is talking about this.
And I thought it was insane
kind of because I'm watching
the games this weekend.
And they go, "Ugh, we have to
announce Tom Brady is retiring."
And then they do a whole
documentary, slow motion of
him walking out on the field,
and they go,
"And also, he hasn't really
decided if he's retiring."
[ Laughter ]
"Okay, I'm sorry."
We just watched a whole
documentary of how great he was.
What's your lead on this?
Is he retiring? Is he not?
-Yeah, I'm not sure
I have the answer.
But I think
if Tom's going to retire,
I feel like he'll announce it
himself.
That's kind of the process that
I went through when I retired.
Jimmy in 2011 when I got injured
with the Colts,
there were a lot of rumors
whether I was going to
come back and play or not.
Rob Lowe tweeted out
that he knew firsthand
that I was about to retire.
And I had to call a press
conference to actually say,
"You know, I always thought I
would announce my retirement,
not the guy that played Sodapop
Curtis in 'The Outsiders.'"
[ Laughter ]
-You'd think.
-I feel like Tom is
in that same boat a little bit.
Like, I think he'll make
the announcement
at the appropriate time.
It might be tomorrow.
It might be in April.
It might not be till three years
from now, he's playing so well.
So I don't imagine
Tom's too happy
with the news this weekend.
But I think he will announce it
whenever,
at the appropriate time,
on his own terms, as he should.
-Yeah, I agree. Good man.
Peyton, you're one of
the greatest quarterbacks
to ever play the game.
And then I saw you throw out
a first pitch
at an all-star game.
[ Laughter ]
Should we show the clip?
-No. No clip, please. No clip.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Please.
[ Drumroll ]
-I'm sorry. Don't look.
Cover your eyes.
Cover your eyes for one second.
Let's just take a look
real quick.
Here's Peyton Manning throwing
out the first pitch here.
-Alright, now,
now, it's very hard.
I've done it myself and failed.
It's harder than you think.
-Yeah.
It was bad all the way around.
First off, they were
supposed to have
two Colorado Rockies players
do it.
One got COVID.
The other had knee surgery.
So, they bring in the
third-string quarterback, right?
The third stringer should not be
throwing out the first pitch
at an all-star game, Jimmy.
-You're the third-stringer here.
-Yeah.
I wasn't mentally prepared.
I had one-day notice.
I didn't get a lot of practice.
And I got too much coaching.
Max Scherzer told me
to throw it hard.
Ohtani told me just get it
over the plate.
I couldn't make my mind up.
I'm winding up.
I'm like, "Throw it hard,
throw it hard.
No, no, throw it soft."
And I'm in between.
And I threw an interception
right in the dirt.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, what's
the statute of limitations
on when that video
stops being played?
Eli I feel like is
behind this episode
and making you show that video.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Eli had a little bit
to do with it.
I remember the first time
I met you and your brother,
we were in Indianapolis at --
Oh, no.
We were in Kentucky
at the Kentucky Derby.
-Kentucky. Kentucky Derby.
-And the Colts were there
and you were there with Eli.
And I jumped on stage to sing
with the band
or something like that and I was
dating my now-wife at the time.
And it came down and all
the Colts were there,
and I go, "Where's Nancy?
Where's my girlfriend?"
They go, "She's the best, man.
She's so cool."
I go, "I know. Where is she?"
They go, "She's partying with
the Mannings."
And she was next to you and she
was chugging a bottle of vodka.
And I was like, "You don't do
that. What are you doing?"
She was like,
"These guys are so fun."
-My Colts teammates loved her.
They wanted her to draft her to
come back to play for our team.
She is one of us.
[ Laughter ]
-The Manning brothers.
It was so fun.
We had the best time.
"Manningcast" can't be funnier,
can't be better,
so well-produced, well-done.
It's you and your brother
making fun of each other.
But also you're geniuses
about football.
-Yeah. I mean Jimmy, it's just
something different.
We were real happy
that ESPN kind of wanted
to do something different.
Eli and I thought
they were joking.
"Wait a minute, you're going to
pay us to watch football
with my brother from our house?"
[ Laughter ]
Like, I know I went to Tennessee
and Eli went to Ole Miss,
but I think we can figure out
this sounds like a lot of fun
and a pretty good deal.
We get to be home
on the weekends with our kids
and coach their sports and still
stay close to the game of
football, talking about it
in a fun way.
We had some great guests
on this year,
all people that love football.
But it's a lot of fun to do it
with my brother, Jimmy.
You know, he's in New York,
I'm in Denver.
We don't see each other as much
as we used to.
So for he and I have to have
this together every Monday
or 10 Mondays in the fall,
it's been a lot of fun.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright. Quickly, Super Bowl.
Now it's down to
Bengals versus Rams.
I don't know if anyone saw
this coming.
I didn't. But I have no idea
who's going to win.
I don't even know who has
the advantage or disadvantage.
-Well, obviously the puppy race
tells it all.
It's definitely going to be
Bengals, right?
-Ron beat Gary.
Look, I'm so pumped for
these quarterbacks, right?
Matthew Stafford, 13 years,
right?
You know, he's been taking
a lot of heat.
Can he win the big one,
all that?
I'm so glad he's there.
And Joe Burrow is just Mr. Cool,
right?
I mean, to be in a Super Bowl --
in his first Super Bowl
so early in his career.
Both these guys
will handle the moment.
You know, obviously one of them
is going to come away a winner.
I've been on both sides of it.
There's no feeling
like to win it, Jimmy.
It is as disappointing as you
think it would be not to win it.
So I'm pulling for
both quarterbacks.
It's going to be a great game
without a doubt.
-A legend right there.
Peyton Manning, everybody.
Check out his commercial also
during the big game.
You're doing Michelob?
-Michelob Ultra.
Just like you did, man.
-Michelob Ultra, baby!
That's my jam! I love it!
Check out his commercial
during the big game.
We love you, pal.